there's an EU in or an EU out the
perfect photo opportunity for the pro at
mixing pints with politics
EU lt's a nigel Farraj wasted no time
getting stuck in cheers everybody
Harrogate the latest stop on the leave
means leave tour the North Yorkshire
town voted to remain but Farraj was
among friends in the pub it was just get
on with it I'm getting sick of it let's
just drag it on and on since the
referendum we've been told brexit means
brexit now here we're being told leave
means leave but we are where we are and
does anyone really know where that is
it's not so much where we are as where
we're going the message aboard the
brexit bus you'll notice nick promises
about cash for the NHS on this one so
what does nigel farage think about the
prospect of another referendum if
Parliament can't decide and it looks
like Parliament is just locked
what kind of exit MPs want to see isn't
the only other answer to go back to the
peaceful in Adams there we vote leave
against them what happens do they
continue to ignore us this is I mean
this is a matter of trust this is about
a whole democratic system greatest
exercise in democracy ever seen in this
country around 1200 of his supporters
turned up to this rally as they arrived
they were reminded by protesters which
way the town voted inside they heard
from speakers across the political
divide it wouldn't be so much a people's
vote as a losers vote they say No Deal
no problem they just want out with no
further delays Becky Johnson Sky News
Harrogate